Oh Merseyside police on a mission to
dismantle five county lines criminal
drug operations running from Liverpool
to towns in North Wales so once we're at
the dawn we've got entry I'll go through
first the dealers who run the lines use
children as runners and expose them to
danger and violence while hoping to keep
all the nastiness from their own front
door well that plan came crashing down
today for a number of suspects this was
a coordinated operation at fifteen
addresses in Liverpool and four other
towns involving a hundred and twenty
officers the 37 year old man was
arrested at this house suspected of
running an operation 50 miles away in
rill these kind of police raids now
happen every week in Liverpool but
what's unusual about this one is that
the Home Secretary was watching today
also viewing a search operation by the
British Transport Police
Priti Patel spoke exclusively to Sky
News about her plans to tackle the
problem
start to understand County lives but
importantly tackle county lines drafts
the gangs the perpetrator the
individuals and the organizations behind
county lines so we can quite literally
cut the head of the snake and get to the
very root causes the upstream causes of
why county lines has become such an
issue in this country Sky News has
previously investigated County lines
from crack houses to Mules carrying
drugs on trains to market places like
here in Southend where one youth said
he'd been stabbed by someone running a
drug line every wassup everyone stats
this week show knife crime was at its
highest recorded level last year it's
increased linked to the spread of county
lines and associated youth violence
critics say that the Conservatives have
created the conditions under which
County lines has thrived so for example
young people have become more vulnerable
because of austerity or cuts to mental
health services and in particular cuts
to youth services but not known for her
soft side
the Home Secretary acknowledged today
there needs to be investment and
improved opportunities for those young
people at risk first and foremost we
have to safeguard children we've got to
protect them in their communities and
stop them from even falling into this
awful death trap we're not speaking
about a handful of children thousands of
children go missing every year thousands
of children are being exploited across
our country that is all for that cannot
be allowed and that's something we've
got to get on top of the try and stop it
can't be achieved by policing alone but
Boris Johnson has pledged to totally
wind up every county line and it's this
woman who's tasked with fulfilling that
ambition
Jason Ferrell Sky News